bonjour gérard respire merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors on
l'a dit on l'a entendu le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan affirmé aujourd'hui
que la turquie donnera à la grèce la
réponse qu'elle mérite
et qu'est ce que ça signifie
concrètement ça signifie que la
président turquie est toujours fidèle à
sa ligne à savoir une gesticulation par
le verbe et un accompagnement donc par
des moyens de pression réelle militaires
ou autres avec par exemple la présence
de ce navire de recherche sismique donc
il y à un modèle diplomatique turque on
bouge un militairement un rôle voir
aussi vit on le voit en liban en libye
pardon on le voit donc aussi maintenant
dans le caucase on a le verbe haut
mais tout cela conduit finalement un
fort isolement de la turquie d'un point
de vue diplomatique à les états unis
donc et la turquie sont maintenant bande
dans des tensions la russie et la
turquie sont également de rétention
l'union européenne la turquie et la
chine ce n'est pas aussi très très
positif puisqu'il y aller oui go que la
turquie défend avec beaucoup de tension
donc voyez vous il y à un isolement
diplomatique turque qui se dessine avec
une situation économique de plus en plus
difficile vous éduquez vous évoquiez
tout de suite les etats-unis qui ont
estimé que la mission d'un navire à
d'exploration gazière en méditerranée
orientale étaient une provocation
délibérée
quel peut être le rôle joué par les
états unis dans ce cas de figure il ya
d'abord les mots et les maux
effectivement des deux côtés de
l'atlantique sont les mêmes
le mot provocation été prononcé par un
morgan octopus la porte parole du
département d'état à washington et sont
les mots du ministre des affaires
étrangères allemand n'est ce pas
provocation donc il y a une volonté de
cadres et ankara de façon diplomatique à
mais aussi de dire et je la prochaine
fois si ça continue on se dirige jeu
r des sanctions il ya déjà eu des
sanctions à l'occasion donc de l'achat
des f 400 rue ce point par ankara à la
suppression de la fourniture des avions
militaires américains f 35a la
suppression de la fourniture de pièces
par l'industrie turque pour l'ensemble
du marché mondial de cet avion
donc il y à des moyens de pression
économique qui sont en arrière-plan si
la turquie franchi un nouveau seuil
vous parliez tout de suite ce mot
provocation et il est assez fort a
prononcé par les états unis par
l'allemagne
est ce que l'otan doit jouer un rôle
dans ce conflit et l'europe aussi à tout
à fait toute façon les deux sont alliés
en termes géopolitiques
donc il y à une communauté bruxelloise
l'otan et le siège de l'union européenne
sont tous les deux à bruxelles donc
voilà il ya des moyens de parler on doit
parler la turquie et a rejoint l'otan en
1953 à trois ans avant l'allemagne dit
de l'ouest à l'époque donc voilà c'est à
un membre nos parts fondateur mais c'est
un membre historique puisque le temps
est né en 1949 donc 1953 vraiment très
proche et il s'agit de raison garder à
la turquie a un rôle à jouer
est ce que le rôle du président r de
gamme sera éternelle vous parliez tout à
l'heure de possibles sanctions quelle
sanction pourra imaginer sur la turquie
écoutez la turquie est dans une
situation économique très difficile à
vous avez un taux de chômage qui est
remonté à plus de 14% ça veut dire qu'il
ya un taux de chômage de 20 25 % dans la
population jeune il y à un taux
d'inflation de 12 % un taux de la banque
centrale de 10% a donc voilà une
situation très très lourde avec un taux
de croissance qui a décliné depuis allez
7% de 2010 est maintenant à à 0 9 %
l'année dernière moins 5% donc
régression cette année la pente
économique de la turquie elle est très
mauvaise
elle est isolée diplomatiquement
le président erdogan joue un jeu très
très difficile
est-ce qu'il va tenter des élections
anticipées parce que s'il attend le
terme il pourrait être à nouveau en
difficulté comme il l'a été
politiquement lors des élections
municipales
merci beaucoup gérard respire d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur rtl france
rappelle vous êtes analyste géopolitique
et fondateur du site le monde décrypté
merci beaucoup merci à vous